cila Harris is uh out on the campaign
Trail I want you to listen to this uh I
can't even call it an interview uh
whatever this is this exchange between
Harris and a CNN reporter
listen let me ask you one more question
it I'm struck just in your presence the
I was watching you on stage watching the
reactions from the crowd looking you in
the eye with your passion that you were
displaying and talking about so many
issues and yet you you hear candidates
suggesting that a vote for President
Biden because of his age is somehow a
vote for you and that is hurled as an
insult it's intended to demonstrate some
negative Viewpoint towards
you what is your reaction to this
thought that with your background in
particular with your career that there
is some thought that you are
incapable well I I think that um most
women who have risen in their profession
who are leaders in their profession have
had similar
experiences um I was the first woman to
be elected district attorney I was the
first woman to be elected attorney
general in the state of California and
I'm the first woman to be vice
president and I love my
job I'm struck in your presence she says
she is in awe
she practically has tears whing up in
her eyes she's in awe in the presence of
CA
Harris
um I mean you you
cannot overstate just how laughably
ridiculous that statement is when
applied to ca Harris of all people one
of the most unimpressive people in a
government filled to the brim with
midwit and
mediocrities you're in all it's like
saying you're
I don't know you're struck by the beauty
and Grandeur of a potato it it just
doesn't how can you have that emotion in
the presence of that thing it's like
you're sitting staring at a potato on
the
table sobbing in tears tears of joy as
you stare at the potato I I can't how do
you conjure up those
emotions um in the presence of something
like that but never mind all that you
you are a reporter uh you are a
journalist and this exchange it's
indistinguishable from like what you
might hear a reporter in North Korea say
to the supreme
leader of of North Korea the total lack
of skepticism um of
criticism from the media to our
political leaders continues to
be shameful and disgusting to behold and
I know that we talk about it all the
time everyone complains about it so it's
it's nothing new
but it is uh it's only getting worse and
honestly it's a problem on both sides
it it it's worse on the left but you
could find it all over the right too um
you know if you're a republican
politician you know where you can go you
can't go on CNN but um well some
Republican politicians could even go on
CNN and get and
get and and get lavish praise as well um
but you know you you know where you can
go in media somewhere in Fox News and
you can get you can get uh coverage that
is almost as fawning as that how many
people in Media can you
name that we can rely on to hold a
politician's feet to the fire regardless
of party or politics how many like how
many people are in media right now
reporters
journalists who
actually not only are willing to uh be
skeptical of politicians and to hold
their feet to the fire and hold them
accountable but like enjoy doing it
because that that's the thing that that
that should Propel you to get into that
line of work in the first place should
of course it's clear that's not what's
happening
is there
anyone that's an honest question is
there anyone you can think of in media
who who uh is in a position of
interviewing politicians and stuff all
the time and covering the news and you
could rely on them doesn't matter who
the person is they're going to ask tough
questions there might be a few but it's
it is a vanishingly small
number um and uh but this is this is
even worse than usual and and actually
what she the framing of the question is
kind of funny that we just heard because
it sounds almost passive aggressive it's
not because this person really is this
reporter actually is like the president
of the ca Harris fan club she's the
president and also the only card
carrying member but it does sound
passive AGG aggressive you know she's
she's saying you know
everybody everyone in the world
apparently thinks that a big argument
against Joe Biden is the fact that
you're second in line why does everyone
think
that it's a it sounds like a passive
aggressive kind of argument or question
and of course CA immediately reaches for
the sexism card she says it's because
she's a woman when in reality it's
because she's an insufferable
incompetent phony fraudulent woman who
has never accomplished a single thing in
her life on her own Merit that that's
the part that people don't like it's
it's not it's not the woman part it's
all the stuff that comes before that
it's all the it's all the additional
descriptions that we can apply to you
before we get to
woman but she said because she it's a
woman which is of course the expected
response and it seems to me like this
kind of self-victimization the pulling
the sexism card stuff it it's becoming
more and more common we talked a few
days ago about how Republican women are
doing this constantly now Nikki Haley
Nancy mace margerie Taylor green just in
the last like week have had their own
moments where they say I'm only being
interrupted because I'm a woman what a
woman can't
speak so here's another question we just
have that question about are there any
truly honest uh journalists left is
there a female
politician in existence who will not
pull the sexism card when given the
chance maybe there is so I'm sincerely
asking for an
example because like there there are
plenty of black and racial minority
politics on the right anyway who will
specifically repudiate the racism card
uh V ramaswami did it many times even
somebody like Tim Scott now he'll play
the race card sometimes but on occasion
he'll he'll also refute it I guess
depending on how he's feeling that day
but the whole uh you're attacking me
because I'm a woman thing I'm I'm
genuinely asking is there a single
female politician who doesn't make that
move when given the
opportunity is there a single female
politician who if you ask her do people
doubt you because you're a woman will
respond by saying what no but women are
not persecuting this country women are
doing fine women in fact they doing
better than men by every available
metric the whole women are being
oppressed thing is is is done it's over
you you if you want to make that claim
you have nothing to hang it
on is there any female politician who
will say
that I hope there is uh but this stuff
is it's so pervasive now
I don't know Marsha Blackburn she's one
I've never heard her play the sexism
card so there's one we got one does she
stand alone I don't know um okay
uh well staying on C Harris just for a
moment to quote Willie Brown She also
appeared on The View where she enjoyed
uh um being the smartest person in the
room for once which is a joke that I
have just stolen directly from the
Babylon be full-on plagiarism um but she
was on the show and she she tried to
explain what she thinks is the top
concern of parents everywhere and uh
here's what she says what they are
telling me in state after state is that
they are concerned about the future of
our country um many of us often think
about the future of our country in the
context of our
children and so they talk about their
concern that if their daughter is going
to college will she go to a state where
she will have access to the health care
she might need including reproductive
Health
um and so this is a top concern of
parents is is uh is that is quote
unquote reproductive Health we know what
that means uh and that of course is a
horrific thing to say she that that the
the top concern of parents is that their
kids are able to kill their own
kids and listen Maybe that's true for
some parents Maybe there are some
mothers who will say to their college
age daughters hey you know you can't go
to college there because if you conceive
my grandchild there uh you will not be
able to immediately kill
him I'm sure there are some parents who
do say that or words that mean the same
thing um to their kids but it is just
horrifically demonically
evil and this is why we can never
surrender this issue or deemphasize it
or stop talking about it or any of the
things that the Cowardly conservatives
in our midst wants want us to do this is
something that some conservatives who
are maybe what what we would call Casual
pro-lifers um but are not really
invested in the movement this is
something they don't
understand and if you're in that
category if you're one of these pro-life
casuals who uh now have the opinion that
especially as we get into election he's
oh you know let's let's not go too far
let's not talk about it very much you
know having a heartbeat bill it's way
too far we can't do
that and what is with the rest of you
conservative why why can't you just stop
talking about well what you don't
understand is that those of us in this
Movement we are here because we have
seen what abortion is and we can't unsee
it we can't and when I say we've we've
seen it I don't necessarily mean that we
have personal experience with it
although there are plenty of
post-abortive women who are in the
pro-life movement and I don't
necessarily mean that we've seen the
victim images of of what of what the
babies look like after having been
killed by abortion although most of us
have seen
those what I mean is that we have
intellectually allowed ourselves to face
abortion and see it for what it is which
is the actual killing of human
life so that when we say abortion kills
babies and you say abortion kills babies
we really mean
it okay and and once you do that once
you see it for what it is you you can't
unsee it you can't pretend you didn't
see
it so once you really say you really
truly say and see and believe that this
is the violent destruction of human
children there's no coming back from it
you
can't because then you have realized
that this is the greatest evil being
perpetrated in the world today and you
will never be able to convince yourself
that the economy or taxes or whatever
are more
important you cannot do it it's not
possible so that so that is that's
that's the difference
right as someone someone's really in the
pro life movement and someone who just
casually Republican doesn't really care
the difference between us and you is
that on abortion we basically say the
same things but we believe it you only
pretend
to and and and so the disconnect between
our two factions can be explained that
way because once you really believe that
this is a holocaust of The
Unborn that has claimed 60 million lives
like the idea that we should move on
from it is absurd it's like if it wasn't
so morbid you would laugh at it move Mom
what are you talking about to what what
what's more
important um and you can't you can't
answer that if You' like to see what
else I have to say you can access my
full show by going to dailywire.com or
by going to the Matt wall Show Twitter
page hope to see you there godp speed